avec nous maintenant en direct en direct
du mur de berlin
philippe rochot philippe une question
toute simple pour commencer philippe
vous êtes vous ce matin et que se
passe-t-il autour de vous écoutez nous
sommes à checkpoint charlie
vous savez que c'était le point de
passage réservé aux étrangers et là tout
le monde les allemands de l'est se
mélangent aux polonais qui d'habitude
passent la frontière pour aller vendre
au marché noir leur caviar sur postdamer
platz et vous voyez ici il ya une file
d'attenté d'environ 300 mètres pour
passer il faut attendre une heure et
demie et puis de l'autre côté également
il y à trois cents mètres de files
d'attentes d'allemands de l'est qui
veulent venir passer le week end à
l'ouest alors ce qui est intéressant de
noter c'est que sur le mur que vous
voyez ici en bas on a refait les
inscriptions c'est à dire qu'on a marqué
le 10 novembre comme une date vraiment
historique
et puis on me signale que monsieur
rostro bugis rostropovitch qui se trouve
précisément à berlin ouest
ici à checkpoint charlie va jouer se
prépare à jouer
je ne sais pas si nous aurons le temps
de l'entendre daniel oui on vient
l'argent tout cas là je crois que c'est
un événement quand même extraordinaire
c'est à dire que chacun va venir saluer
à sa taille
l'ouverture du mur bien alors on a dit
on a dit philippe urbain on va aller
c'est monsieur rostropovitch bien sûr se
prépare et si on a le temps de
l'entendre on l'entendra où elle
repassera à la fin du journal
philippe on a ce matin ouvert le mur en
plusieurs endroits je crois qu'on va
avoir des images qui vont venir couvrir
ce que vous allez nous dire à propos de
ces ouvertures au moins neuf ou dix
endroits où on en a carrément on le voit
sur les images ou vers le mur à la
pelleteuse
oui on a ouvert le mur à la pelleteuse
on va creuser
aussi pour mettre des dalles pour
permettre le passage des gens ça fait
une brèche de trois mètres à peu près et
ce qui était extraordinaire ce matin
c'était se trouvait comme nous l'avons
fait entre les deux murs puisque
finalement il y avait deux mur qui
séparait berlin et au milieu à no man's
land de se trouver là au milieu avec
cette foule de gens qui passaient et
d'hélicoptères il y avait vraiment une
très belle une très belle vue puisque
c'était ce désert ce no man's land avec
cette foule qui traversait et puis qui
symbolisait finalement là l'unité de ces
berlinois entre eux qui n'ont jamais
finalement cessé de pouvoir se parler
mais qu'il ne pouvait pas tous se
rencontrer bien philippon voilà monsieur
hippolyte va on va se quitter ou alors
on attend 6 6 il commence pour nous
pourquoi dans quelques minutes parce que
je crois que c'est un moment à ne pas à
ne pas manquer c'est à c'est quand même
à saluer c'est bien alors on attend
quelques secondes philippe écouter voilà
tout de suite il se prépare donc si
notre j'espère qu'on aura la bernard
enflait peut apporter
l'image d'abord rivage la caméra sur
onze reprises dont les cet hommage
kidron à ce moment historique de notre
histoire d'après-guerre rassure les
poules voilà non moi ça n'a aucun
intérêt qu'on repasse sur monsieur
rostropovitch si c'est possible a tout
de suite commencé
voilà on se tait
m
voilà ce moment que vous avez réussi
grâce à nos installations en direct de
berlin à vivre et que nous ferons bien
survivre dans notre édition de 20h ce
soir mais c'était important d'écouter un
instant cette musique dans cet
environnement